in this capsule we will look at the
different types of environments that
can meet in intelligence
artificial
so how do we live in the model near
among other things is the notion
of environment we have distinguished where we have
rather a meryl
what are the elements that can
belong the environment in the
context a given application what
will be particularly practical
when come the time to identify
what intelligence algorithms
artificial
we will want to use for a
given application it's going to be from
distinguish which types of environment
and specifically what are the
properties of the environment to which one
faces then what are these properties
lake we will look in this capsule
we will distinguish among others six
properties or type of environment one
going to talk about environment completely
observed observable forgiveness versus
partially observable environment
deterministic versus stochastic
the episodic environment versus
sequential static environment
versus discrete environment dynamics
versus continuous and finally
of single agent versus
multi-agents let's look at these different
types or properties in the environment
so both as the property we are going
say that an environment is
completely observable 6 thanks to its
sensors the agent access to the complete state
of the environment at every moment everything
throughout his life for example
the environment associated with a game
chess is completely observable
since the position of all the parts
of the game is constantly known to age in
has none that are hidden is observable
by the opposite player in the code of
poker game ben it's an environment
partially observable because between
other one of the players does not know the
cards in the hands of his opponent
so according to information that is not
accessible to the agent so
the environment is partially
observable then we have
deterministic environments that these are
environments where the following rates
of the environment is entirely
determined by the state runners and
the action that is performed by the
agents so an example not yet a
times with the chess game it's a
environment that is going to be deterministic
if a determined player who wants to move
a room that will necessarily give the
same result
there will not be a random aspect the
moving the piece will be able to the
move exactly where he wants noting
that it respects the rules of the game is to
the opposite in a poker game like a
once we're going to talk about an environment
which stochastic among others because
distribution of cards to players
is done randomly what makes
that given the configuration of the game
the cards that I slept even well in
two different parts I'm going
possibly obtain as a card
next two cards that are going to be
different
an important note to identify on
the environment and deterministic or not
we consider that the renault
stochastic
if the phenomena can not be
predicted perfectly so is so a
aspect finally in the environment
however, we do not take into account
actions of other agents for
determine whether deterministic or not so
among other things in the game code
chess even if we are not able
to predict exactly what the other
opponent the other agent could do
like action we do not consider that
as part of the environment
the arranged one aspect is paris and the
we can not predict
his strategy is not that
the environment him and stochastic so
we do not want to finally consider our
ability to predict what the opponent
will do to the port as a factor
to determine whether the environment and
deterministic or not even
episodic environments versus
sequential so in the camp
episodic operations the
money behaviors are divided
is
it's among others every episode goes
match to observe the environment
then did a single action and
crucially this action is not going
influence the environment that is going to be
observed in the next episode so a
example would be a context of
character recognition where we
hostage to the image of a
character then this one has to determine
what character does it correspond to
its actually character detection
the traits to which letter of the alphabet
corresponds the image that corresponds to
the image of a character drawn by
someone so in this case also the
system prediction will not influence
what is the next character that the
system must be to recognize
so we are in the code of a
episode during an environment
episodic
on the other hand in the case of poker and
would also be true in the code of
chess game but our actions he will come
obviously an impact on in what
environment will end up that layton
have really found in the next step
among others to continue to a day
why you have to put a bet if not
part or at least this round does
stop for us who so clearly
a notion of dependency of states of
the environment between different in one
given time
we will also talk about an environment
static if the environment does not change
when the agent (s) therefore do not act
an example is the game of chess game
chess and static ie
the game state the game configuration does not
change yet so long that
no one played the reverse in the
play of the ball the ball she continues to
move even if the player moves him
not his palette on it to try to
block the ball
he notes important again we do not
will not take into account the actions of
other rage to determine if a
static environment or not it's up to
to say that it is correct
we are still in an environment
static if the other agent can change
the environment
so we're really interested in this case
also to identify static or not
is the environment changing
when none of the agents move you
do anything we will then say
that the environment is unobtrusive if the
number of sensory data and
action is limited and buried râble
so distinct from a chess gift
we actually have an environment that
is discreet that is to say that all
possible actions and states of the game
can be listed there is one
very very serious exponential number
but we could list them as a result
others while if we're in the
context of a taxi robot driving
automatically car but we would
rather in a continuous environment
because between the angle of not knowing how to fly
here it's flying here
and as for the number and for example the
game pong also we could say that
it's the continuous environment because
the position of the ball is finally a
position xy mutzig rection would count
to many continues
then we will distinguish
Single Agent Versus
multi-agents in the case of an agent
unique is that we have one agent who
operates so is there alone in
the environment
an agent who solves sudokus would
act and in an agent environment
unique since no opponent while
that chess game and multi agenda this
that if two deputies two agents pardon
there is the player and his opponent there is
some cases where the border between a
property and its inverse is difficult to
identify
so for example for the game pogne
conceptually the position of the ball
thought himself simple to have it as
a pair of real numbers but
obviously in a day number in
a table we have a finite number of pixels
so technically we could list
all positions of the bad
however since conceptually that
is more like a number and we're going
still say in a general way that a
game like the game the pen is a player
environment continues same thing
then for the code of moving a
robot if the robot is alone in his
environment we can perfectly
determined is it's displacement
perfect whether alone or not
general since the physical mechanics
or physics that mechanics yes
deterministic there is no aspect
stochastic however model a
physical environment we move you
something so complex that we
may not possibly simulate a
perfect environment and the
way of doing it is going to be rather of
consider that some uncertainty
the in relation the result of the action
robots in a physical environment
and there will normally be an aspect
stochastic so the generation named to
thouars in a simulator of a robot
in a physical environment so in
often does a way to bring
to identify the characteristics or
properties of an environment that's
think about commenting on what
would program or simulate this
environment again the robot because
that we would not be able to do everything
model the expectations of
the environment in which they are
move over to have a system based
on equations of mechanical physics
well determined we will rather simplify
things with a model that is
relatively stochastic where we are going
ask that I have some probability
that the movement of a robot to certain
mistakes because they do not control
perfectly these movements so so
really when we start thinking about
comment on what characterizes a
environment but in fact we think
to comment on this sad supplement this
environment the machine if we equate
ray or as part of a robot too
is really it was a software agent
who is actually in a in a
simulated environment so think about
how do we say we will implement
identify which are the
properties of the environment